als brek sie befürworte rinn ist
journalistin katie bors gerade sehr
beschäftigt trotzdem hat sie sich vor
dem großen tag noch zeit für unsere
fragen genommen
was wird anders sein wenn man am samstag
morgen aufwacht nicht 4s wird sich nicht
sofort etwas verändern
es ist genauso wie wenn man fragt ob der
brh exit das leben der menschen
verändern wird es gibt einige warnungen
und auch positive vorhersagen aber wir
werden das für einige jahre noch nicht
wissen wie es wirklich ausgeht also wird
sich morgen nicht direkt etwas verändert
haben außer vielleicht dass die leute
einen kater haben weil sie in der nacht
gefeiert haben es wird anders sein wenn
die menschen am ersten januar 20 21
aufwachen
ich denke mehr ich denke es wird einige
dinge geben die aber noch nicht so
offensichtlich sind mit der
reisefreiheit wird es dann sicherlich
vorbei seien und die zahlungen an die eu
werden sich verändert haben
aber wie die zukünftige beziehung
aussieht und wie sich das dann auf die
wirtschaft auswirkt kann man noch nicht
sagen aber ich denke 20 21 werden sich
wirklich schon dinge im land verändert
haben
was würdest du den remains vorschlagen
keep calm and carry on oder gehen das
land verlassen
na ja keiner sollte das land wegen des
drecks it verlassen
der ganze prozess war schon sehr
zermürbend für unser land
aber ich denke nach den letzten
wahlergebnissen dem sieg für boris
johnson mit einer mehrheit von 80 sitzen
war es sehr klar dass der praxis kommt
einige meiner freunde die für den
verbleib gestimmt haben sind zwar nicht
begeistert aber sie haben sich damit
abgefunden
gerade weil wir jetzt mit einem deal
gehen das hat die nerven erst mal
beruhigt wir werden elf monate für die
weiteren verhandlungen mit der eu
ausreichen wenn man auf brüssel hört
nein
fragt man in westminster heißt es ja ich
denke wir sind an einem punkt wo man
alle aussagen mit vorsicht genießen muss
von beiden seiten
wir sind in der zweiten phase der
verhandlungen und man kann da nicht
alles für voll nehmen auf ein paar
punkte kann man sich sicherlich einigen
als ein vorteil für das vereinigte
königreich ist
dass man zeit druck ausüben kann boris
johnson wollte das ja schon immer um so
die eu in eine richtung zu drücken
bisher konnten sie das nie machen auch
theresa may nicht weil keine mehrheit im
parlament da war und die abgeordneten
hatten die regierung in der hand ich
denke jetzt wo sie das machen könnten
ist es nicht die frage ob es als taktik
funktioniert aber es ist eine bessere
position für das vereinigte königreich
in den verhandlungen kann irgendwas
diese zerrissene gesellschaft wieder
vereinen
ich weiß nicht wie zerrissen wir
wirklich sind
wir hatten sicherlich harte jahre bei
allem was hier in der politik passiert
ist die ganze unentschlossenheit hat
nicht geholfen
im unterhaus ist keine einzige
entscheidung durchgekommen wir hatten
ein parlament ohne mehrheit die tories
waren gespalten genauso wie labour einen
solchen austritt wollte glaube ich
niemand ich denke es gibt dem ganzen
jetzt einen abschluss man kann endlich
wieder über andere sachen sprechen
einige meiner freunde fragen jetzt
worüber sollen wir uns denn jetzt
streiten
in zehn jahren wird man immer noch
großbritannien sagen oder klein brettern
ich denke nicht dass wir klein
britannien sind ich denke nicht dass wir
den namen unseres landes ändern werden
nur wegen des drecks it der interessante
frage ist was mit der union passiert es
gibt da einige herausforderungen für das
vereinigte königreich im nächsten jahr
wenn man auf ein mögliches
unabhängigkeitsreferendum in schottland
schaut und wieder wechselt für
nordirland funktionieren wird
das ist einer der knackpunkte in dem
deal ich denke dass unsere regierung
alles tun wird um das vereinigte
königreich zusammenzuhalten dosis und
großbritannien in zehn jahren
ich denke wir werden noch aus der eu
heraus seien einige fragen sich wie
lange es wohl braucht wieder einzutreten
ich denke sobald man einmal raus ist ist
es viel schwieriger wieder reinzukommen
das was wir in der eu hatten war
besonders wie wäre es dann wenn wir
wieder eintreten wollen das ist vor
allem interessant im blick auf die
demografie jüngere wähler waren eher pro
eu man kann nicht ausschließen dass es
bemühungen für den wiedereintritt geben
wird aber wir müssten dann viele
komplizierte fragen beantworten zum
beispiel über den euro ich denke wir
werden immer noch aus der eu heraus sein
was soll das mit dem schmetterling auf
dem letzten cover der schmetterlinge
bedeutet dass wir uns auf etwas zu
bewegen ein neues positives kapitel der
brh exit ist nicht notwendigerweise
brillant aber er öffnet türen wenn die
regierung und die leute es richtig
angehen und das soll der titel bedeuten